so I guess this is just gonna be how
Matt Grammy stays busy now that Disney
owns the Simpsons disenchantment season
two is out on Netflix I reviewed the
first season when it came out however
long ago that was I guess about a year
maybe a little more I don't know I could
go back and check but I'm not gonna
cuz I'm lazy I've now seen season two
and thankfully unlike say Shiraz seasons
two and three it's it wasn't a case of
they took a second season and divvied it
up into two parts this is a proper
second season it is as long as the first
season ten episodes
half an hour of peace now if you didn't
see or don't recall they don't feel like
going back and re watching my review of
the first season quick primer I thought
it had a lot of promise I thought that
the characters most of them were pretty
good the main characters especially the
character of being in particular I
thought was a really high watermark I
enjoyed lucy l foe worked for me more
often than he didn't I had a few issues
elsewhere but I did like how it started
on episodic and then built not only
built and do something more akin to a
grander story but you also realized that
it was seeding bits and pieces for that
grander story as it was doing the
episodic thing kind of under your nose
and a little bit under the radar I
thought that was really good and really
cool so coming into the second season
knowing that basically the hand has
already been tipped as to some of the
bigger stuff going on how's the second
season gonna pick up kind of awkwardly
as it turns out not right off the bat
basically the first three that's six you
[ __ ] do it on one hand the first three
episodes are taken up dealing with the
fallout of what happened at the end of
the previous season's finale I'm not
gonna necessarily cover spoilers on that
no I'm not I'm not gonna spoil a first
season just in case folks haven't seen
it already but basically there was stuff
that happened at the end at the end of
that that has to be addressed
characters certain things were learned
about certain characters certain
characters found themselves
in completely different locations they
needed to be joined together again so
that happens over the course of the
first three episodes of the second
season and then without having truly
resolved you know everything like
dealing with the the stuff that had
disrupted the status quo but not really
resolving the narrative thread front
left over from the previous season it
then just slips back into being a Posada
qug n which was weird I might have gone
with it better if it had started out
episodic right off the bat and just had
a similar structure to the first season
again but it doesn't it starts out
serialized and then goes episodic until
like the last two episodes and it just
doesn't flow this time what worked about
the first season in terms of overall
trajectory of this of this story for the
whole season was that like I said it
snuck its world building or its
narrative things that were going to pay
off later under your nose you didn't
even realize there were things that were
gonna be paid off but you can't pull
that trick a second time because now
we're watching for it but it still kind
of tries to do that and on top of the
fact that it like does you know
continuing off the previous one now back
to practically status quo of the first
season and then like a little like a
little blip on the heart meter at the
end now the the more episodic parts of
the season aren't actually bad they're
no worse or really all that much better
than the episodic and you know parts of
the first season but they just feel like
a step backwards
it's really weird taken as a whole again
watching the episodes individually they
probably work better like honestly none
not so much the first season but this
second season really would have worked
better on a weekly release schedule like
maybe lump the first three episodes
together as like a new season big
special extra like premiere but then
just have it go weekly because binging
through it I found myself going wait
what what but you're not dealing with
the like you're here doing this
but like you had massive stuff left over
that you're just not dealing with like
at all so what and then it's like it
pulls a new villain new sort of
overarching villain out of its but the
the show does towards the very end and
it's not that I don't believe it
yeah I do but like you had other
villains you still haven't dealt with
yet why are you giving us a new one what
ah it's unfocused is what it is is it it
feels like it had a couple of ideas that
weren't enough to sustain too steep a
season so in order to get a full ten
episodes they took the ideas they
actually had coming off of the first
season stuck them at the front in the
end and then just did filler for like
five episodes in the middle of it I'm
actually like I watched it in two days
and I enjoyed it more than I think the
tone in my voice kind of would lead you
to believe at this moment in time but it
was really frustrating and additionally
so because not only do I still like the
characters I like some of the new
characters and some of the characters
who I didn't love before kind of grow on
me so like new characters Jerry is the
best he's not in it enough unfortunately
but Jerry's great I love him if you've
seen the season you know who he is but
bean is still great I really like being
as a character I like kind of her just
how much she subverts the the princess
tropes and in ways that aren't the
standard way they get subverted yes
she's more gung-ho for action whatever
but she's also not the most competent in
the world she's you know she's big into
drinking she makes a lot of bad
decisions she's kind of gross sometimes
and like I like that just as a female
princess lead she is allowed to be these
things sometimes she can be dumb
she's frequently drunk she's a little
gross but she's still a fundamentally
good person I
like being a lot Lucy I still had fun
with elf Oh
although was weird this season because
after spending a decent chunk of the
first three episodes bringing him back
into the story from where things were
left with him at the end of the previous
season the show then doesn't really know
what to do with him like all he does is
just kind of give us a reason to show
stuff going on in elf town every now and
then and otherwise he just kind of
stands around and keeps harping on the
stuff that happened at the end of the
previous season over and over and over
and over again it it's it's annoying
because like those first three episodes
are honestly really good including the
parts that cover how well folk gets
brought back into the fold and reunited
with the other characters and it but
it's annoying that so much work was put
into figuring out how do we get him back
and spending three episodes on doing it
and then he's just kind of they're like
ah but some other characters you did
grow on me a bit more Kings org voiced
by John DiMaggio he was a little bit of
a sticking point for me last time but
that I chalked that up partially to the
fact that I just recognized you
recognize John DiMaggio as voice so
readily that it honestly these days
takes me out of things um but I guess by
this point I just kind of gotten used to
it so I can't it was more endearing to
me as a character maybe he's better
fleshed out or maybe I just got used to
him in he was this good last season I'm
not entirely sure uh so you know he
works and that's and that was nice to
sort of enjoy time with him a bit more
thank God I can't remember his name but
the the guy who got turned into a pig
last season he gets he gets some nice
screen time I had some fun with him and
again like the the one-off stories and
the characters who get introduced in
them aren't bad it's just the
reintroduction of the episodic nature of
the season in the middle of it is just
very very strange to me I'm
this this would be an exaggeration but
like think of any show that you like
that had a two-parter season finale you
know Buffy Season 2 becoming part 1 and
to any of the Doctor Who season finales
because they're all two parters imagine
part one aired and then a season worth
of episodic stuff not really connected
happened and then part two weird this
doesn't quite feel like that it's a
little bit hyperbole but it's not it's
not a million miles off from feeling
like that it's it had a lot of momentum
coming off the first season and it
maintained it for the first three
episodes and then just kind of decides
to go back to what it was like at the
start of the first season and I just
don't know why it's a shame and it's
frustrating I you know I hope no one was
made a drinking game out of taking a
shot every time I said the world
frustrating because that's I've said it
a lot frustrating take a shot so yeah
assistant Chan Miss season - I'm not
gonna bail on it like that's one of the
nice things for me about things that are
you know short ish seasons and the
episodes are only half hour long it
takes more to get me to bail on it so if
this gets the third season I'll probably
still watch it cuz again it'll only take
me 1-2 days the most to burn through and
I'm willing to dedicate that much time
about what like three and a half hours
to you know getting through it and
seeing if it can get better again but
this season was a bit of a letdown some
good stuff in it some good individual
episodes strong start but it just and
and like the jokes and the humor they're
pretty good they're about as good as
last time it just irritated me that
there seemed to be a plan for how the
overall series was going to be built and
now it just looks like well I guess
there kind of wasn't I don't know
disenchantment season 2 you seen it what
did you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drops on me all in the
comments let's talk about it I'm super
proud of myself keeping this a spoiler
free as I did
didn't even spoil season one
additionally subscribe hit the
oh I think I don't know I don't usually
tell people to hit the bell do it anyway
you know as a lark + hit the like
support me a bait you're on helps this
thing and you know so I can eat but you
know there's other stuff to click on
besides but it'd be great if you clicked
on it but you also don't have to because
at the end of the day folks
you're the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]